on December 1st 1955 in Montgomery
Alabama Rosa Parks a member of the
n-double a-c-p
was arrested for refusing to give up her
seat to a white passenger in the colored
section of a local Montgomery bus this
case started a boycott in which the
african-americans refused to ride the
city buses to protest against segregated
seating for Martin Luther King the
commitment to a Gandhian philosophy of
non-violence was really forged during
the Montgomery bus boycott Martin Luther
King jr. was chosen to lead this protest
and a major part of the African American
community joined him a system of car
pools and low taxi fares was put in
action by the Montgomery Improvement
Association from the very beginning of
the Montgomery bus boycott the fact that
people came to the conclusion and - King
helped them that they were actually
supporting their own oppression by
paying money in the slot on the bus and
then going to the back they were
cooperating so one of the first things
people must recognize when they
experience oppression is to what degree
do they participate in their own
oppression on November 13th 1956 the
Supreme Court ruled that segregation on
buses and other public transportation
was against the law on December 20th and
1956 the Montgomery bus boycott ended it
lasted for 381 days another important
area towards astride for freedom was the
field of Education in 1954 the United
States Supreme Court decided that the
segregation of public schools was
unconstitutional
gloria ray call mark was one of the
first in a group of african-american
students to be enrolled at an all-white
public high school in Little Rock
Arkansas
this group was called the Little Rock
Nine when I came to the school the first
day in front of me were the soldiers
from the the governor of Arkansas the
Arkansas National Guard I stood there
with her rifles surrounded the campus of
the school they stood
shoulder-to-shoulder they would not let
us enter the campus when a white student
approached them they would move apart
and let the men so then I thought well
maybe it is just that they only open
rank now and then so I thought that when
I saw a group of white girls going if I
just walk right behind them but I would
get in
oh no when the last white girl went
through they they cause rank again and
they were given orders not to allow any
black student to set foot on the campus
of central high school that day so that
that was that first day
[Music]
and this whole picture I had in my mind
of the wonderful future I had ahead of
me because I would get to go to that
school and learn so much that bubble
just burst with armed force protection
ordered by President Eisenhower Gloria
along with the remaining Little Rock
Nine works courted into the school
despite the smile stone the opposition
against integration in public schools in
public places continued throughout the
country
something the african-american community
fought tirelessly to overcome
[Music]